[Music]
so we doing this yeah I just need to get
some coffee
that's water so it is come on let's get
started this is gonna be so it's good
it's perfect Hey Wow this some of your
best work your input has really made it
come full circle you know what's the
movie without rabbit monkeys exist no
one does that anymore what ever ever
amazing rabbit what do you think
Simeon's comeback huh earth to Donny are
you listening or not I'm sorry I where
were we well I'm thinking it's time we
film something different something other
than a remake okay I'm with you how are
you with Carmen Sandiego
Oh Carmen Sandiego movie except we don't
have Fassett like all those other video
game movies we throw everything we can
into it for example it opens up with the
assassination of Abraham Lincoln
except Lincoln turns around and blows
John Wilkes Booth away
oh is that Carmen Sandiego has stolen a
time machine and she's going back
through history selling all of history's
greatest cores killing Hitler letting
crazy horse win and then stealing all
their shit so the police are not only
trying to arrest it for thievery but
they're also trying to war her the medal
of honor cool I like it it makes it
complex first things first
all our hopes rest on the nostalgia
critic people will love that what did
you say I said all our hopes rest on
nostalgia critics love that and people
will too
well obviously we got our leading lady
we do yeah Rebecca she a friend of yours
and yours what the hell's wrong with you
she's sitting around
Danny are you okay how many people work
here for you meet Quinn and karma you
never heard of a woman named Rebecca
stone who did a one-woman Titanic betta
Turkey two dead the words are sure this
is Malkovich equals balls a cup of warm
Irish milk just like my grandmother used
to drink every night when she would go
to bed it's taste like microwave
Bailey's there's more alcohol Annette
could I possibly fabricated a person out
of nowhere it can't be she seems so real
nope it's always just been you me and
Carl and Quinn who quit
it's Quinn the refrigerator Gwen
Oh came to this warm baby's Bailey is
it's you who I searched the whole
internet public records everything there
is no Quinn but Karla works alone so
lovely done the system interrogation or
but yeah yeah you can go no wait if you
go out there you could disappear just
like everyone else hi Wendy grow the
goatee you didn't have a goatee before
and I think cedar tree it's an upside
down world up sicko teeth that's a
byproduct of drinking too much satellite
schnapps last night
and it was delicious I guess you weren't
out drinking with Quinn man nothing I'm
gonna have myself committed now Danny
it's okay I've already called an
ambulance
Thanks you're a good friend I think we
try I'll tell you what I'll stay with
you until it arrives it doesn't matter
you'll be gone like all the rest of them
Donny I'm not going anywhere
Donny listen let me tell you something
what
[Music]
yeah
you
shit
[Applause]
okay
I ordered the original Odd Couple not
the odd life of Timothy green I only
think it's the real movie I think it's a
pirated version well that's all fine and
good what am I supposed to do with this
oh I see
planted the bag conceived a real movie
grows hot screw yo
gonna regret this
[Music]
all right
God okay so this is supposed to be a
feel-good family film about a couple
that play it's a child in the backyard
no first of all before you grow your
tomato child didn't you think like an
orphanage how are you you can go to an
orphanage there's lots of children there
you can pick them like from a garden and
semitone that's a rule everybody should
get a Jesus kid that's what it is a kid
that popped up with no sex Jesus kid or
Anakin Skywalker has even been high
school so like these people at all
they're all horrible horrible people
that was new that was a new experience
for me you you got balls Timothy green
well I don't know maybe you don't make
the leaves but oh that was something
[Music]
hello hey Louis hey dog what's up I got
a bit of a question for you shoot do you
think it did the right thing ending the
Nostalgia Critic it's just you ever
think we left too early like there's
more things we could have done with them
what do you mean we stopped because we
thought we were done but recently one
new ideas have been coming to my head
such as for example I just saw the odd
life of Timothy green Oh Doug why it
doesn't matter I think it does it was
weird I felt the exact same way I do
when I first started I mean the
excitement the fresh ideas I'm wondering
if I made the right choice well I'm not
sure that I'm the guy who can answer
that for you really it boils down to you
yeah I made a choice you know and just
felt like it was the right time to go
your fans didn't seem to think so oh did
they notice the ass number of emails
asking the critic to come back didn't
seem to tip me off I can't just do it
for the fans though I got to do it
because I want to do it well that's why
it's your choice bottom line if you feel
there's still potential and you can keep
it going for a long time bring them back
but if you think you only have enough
for once in a while just keep it once in
a while and go out on top all right
thanks man oh hey boy oh and Harvey say
hi to Lewis buddy are you convinced that
the characters from your show are real
people tog of course not I'm not
deranged
it's just boy oh and Harvey that are
real so boy yo what are your thoughts on
the subject yeah and what's that
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
now well I'm a nostalgia critic can I
remember it so you don't have to oh this
is about as pretentious sexist and
downright pointless a movie you can ever
see in the sci-fi genre it's corny it's
weird it's downright Savage at times
let's take a look at doomsday machine so
what are you waiting for
hmm you know it's just a matter of time
you're not real you're just a fragment
of mine oh very concerned will
imagination maybe or maybe it's like
what you said before and what did I say
before how a character can become so
real that they cease being a character
they become ingrained in your mind and
you can't get rid of them no matter how
hard you try even to a point where they
take on a life of their own no you are
the Buried remains of some nostalgia
that I have left behind Wow isn't that
cute you're nostalgic for the nostalgia
critic I made a choice I said I'm not
going back and I'm gonna do exactly that
why what's stopping you what am I
supposed to go back to anyway quoting
means of running jokes isn't always
about memes and running jokes it's about
that passion for film and that love of
making people laugh and I know you still
get a hunger for both
Ranas course sent to your stuff you got
still sick and tired that you actually
forgot that you enjoyed remember every
single time you thought you were done
with it you came up with something
better when you had time to think time
to focus time to put that extra effort
in but you add anniversary movies
conventions other shows your own life to
live all the trying to write act and
edit a 20 minute video every single week
face it buddy you aren't done yet it
just hit burnout I'm not going back yeah
then why don't you just make me go away
[Music]
see I told you you can't get rid of me
it's gonna cost you Tinkerbell
[Music]
I don't even get it why would a song
about lyric as stupid as I see you can't
make me disappear what the hell are you
doing in my video piss off outright
Hitchcock get the hell out you get the
hell out I live here
you know what bite me in Hamburglar
[Music]
say ever Google do a barrel roll it's
really cool okay that's it hello
what did tell you runes are non neuter
hope Doug are you chewing on something
tranquilizers I've taken enough to kill
a baby right now sorry well that's a
great way to start off a conversation
look you're a friend and I just need you
to be straightforward with me on
something okay and what should I bring
back the nostalgia critic what I mean I
know it won't be entirely impartial
seeing how the static movies are now
your domain and everybody comes to you
for them but I trust you on this and I I
want your honest opinion
no no just like that exactly you made
your choice and you should stick with it
The Critic had a great run but now it's
time to branch out and do new things I
mean do you really want to do this for
the rest of your life well I don't
really think it would of course you
don't so why don't you just stick with
the plan and do what you know is right
yeah you're right I do want to try new
things
thanks a lot Lindsay and a lot of people
in your position would probably have an
agenda but it's good to know you always
give it to me straight
anytime Doug anytime
you know what to do
that's right I'm talking to you you
shouldn't be a nostalgia critic anymore
you should go up and do those new things
everybody loves them don't believe the
haters man just don't be go doing the
sound critic anymore so there
[Music]
yeah pee-wee Herman what are you doing
here it's a dream dreams are like that
come on let's go right Mark Wahlberg
fake peanuts for fucking nights oh boy
he's gonna have some questions when he
wakes up
[Music]
hello hey Brad I'm having a debate on
whether or not to bring the nostalgia
critic back oh I don't care not bring
them back you hear
I got other ideas I want to try new
ideas stuff I've always wanted to do
[Music]
who's to say you can't do your other eye
I'm done talking to you the only one
you'd have to give up it's demo real and
we already know what that was this whole
time
what Donny was this whole time you were
even starting to ride it once again a
character you love is hard to get away
from you dedicated so much time to our
show making sure there was a new episode
every week for over four and a half
years maybe you didn't need to stop
altogether maybe you just needed a break
a chance to take a little time off and
come back fresh and do not ever come
into your mind I'll tell you what if you
answer this honestly I'll go away
forever
tell me right now without any hint of
distrust do you want to do this again do
you have that same passion you had
before that passion for comedy film and
reviewing do you honestly want me to
come back
yes and what are you waiting for
we have work to do
[Music]
some ground rules fair enough
reviews every two weeks wait maybe every
other week I can do a mini review or
film editorial but if we still want
these jokes to still be fresh and funny
I need more time on them and that's
gonna be two weeks so be it
rule 2 No More cut-off dates but I want
to review whatever I want whenever I
want
you're the nostalgia critic it's in your
name we'll review anything currently in
theaters and besides if you're seeing
something after it came out in the
cinema doesn't that technically make it
nostalgic well I guess horrible films
aren't just restricted to one time
period very true
one last condition yes this has to be
the first review why this is the movie
that brought you back that made me
realize I could actually do this again I
feel like I owe it nobody saw it I don't
even know how many people remember it
maybe it's to show that even something
that's regarded as terrible or
forgettable can still inspire something
creative
done all right done what's nice I think
you know what's next
[Music]
hello Donny Wow who are you what are you
I am the creator of a web series that
takes a critical look at nostalgic
movies I I don't understand the person
who are now is the direct result of a
choice a choice you made or the sake of
the plot plot yes you sacrifice yourself
to the plot hole bringing order to chaos
logic to insanity but something went
wrong
what your mind couldn't handle the
paradox of it all and martyrdom it
wouldn't let you believe that you're
capable of such a selfless act well then
what is this where am I
it is a prison a purgatory Forge deepens
depths of your own neuroses and made
flesh as a black hole now at last you
know what it's like to experience
failure will see through the eyes of the
tortured child stars and watch as part
of your unbridled ambition crumbles into
a mangy pile of heap a lifetime of harsh
criticisms termed forest and it's for
precisely these reasons that you need to
come back come back so what I sound like
a fucking maniac
DISA but two hours
[Music]
who was I
oh my god you son of a bitch do you have
any idea how much this shit starred me
do you have any idea that he'll like to
go through here I was a god-awful
filmmaker I made movies that nobody
liked I tried telling everybody my good
intentions but no one ever listened to
me I was a horrible child star actor if
my mother was destroyed by the Hollywood
system this is the worth possible
punishment that could never be demise
for me sweet Jesus tap-dancing Christ
with dinner a show and a kids good night
yes
ah but perhaps now you're a little wiser
everyone you criticize from this point
on has a base in every way they are just
like you they work hard they feel pain
they laugh they cry and when you might
though you also mock yourself you can
still criticize all you want but deep
down inside you always know what it's
like to be on the other side and never
truly forget
so now what now it's time to go back and
review again wait what about the
Platteville I mean I'm listening to keep
it stable and I couldn't do it well
somebody has to sacrifice their life to
obsess over all the little mistakes of
the world it's alright I found someone
obsessed with mistakes and who had no
life worth sacrificing so what are you
waiting for critic there's a whole world
to criticize but wait what about them
they belong to the plot hole now as soon
as you leave but I've gotten to know him
and okay don't worry about this yeah
we've gotten through tougher scrapes
like in our car keys yes we just telling
us sure
yeah I think you learned your lesson if
you ever need a reminder you know what
the point is now walk through that
portal to face your destiny that's an
order thanks guys
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia thing and I'm
back to remembering these of you don't
have to oh oh oh
[Music]
okay I'm gonna be somewhere this up here
[Applause]
[Music]
Coyle that was a very off-color joke you
said don't you agree cyber mats well I
think that nobody cares what you think
after Omega ship nostalgia critic the
fuck is that what are you gonna bring
back Melvin